hi this is Steve Kaufman co-founder of
link I strongly recommend that you
upgrade and I'll give you two big
reasons you can read the attached email
to look at ten good reasons why you
should upgrade but I'm going to give you
two based on my own experience
the first one is unlimited linking
because if you don't upgrade you're only
entitled to twenty links and the second
one is unlimited imports if you study my
statistics in learning seven languages
over the last ten years at link Asian
Slavic Romance different languages I
create a lot of Link's tens of thousands
of links that's how I learned I look up
the word once I see it again highlighted
in yellow and eventually almost without
being aware of it they become part of my
vocabulary so unlimited linking is a key
condition a precondition for learning a
language and the second thing you get
with upgrading is unlimited imports
because after you've explored our own
library at link and studied the
different contents very often beginner
contents you then have to go out and
find things of interest to you and I
import hundreds of articles sometimes
with audio sometimes without audio and
so that it's my interest in these
subjects that keeps me motivated and
which drives me to fluency so there are
many other good reasons why you should
upgrade but those in my view are the two
most important I look forward to seeing
you as a full member of link bye for now
you